a Penn State fraternity is under
investigation today in connection with
another dangerous underage drinking
incident at the school the Delta Tau
Delta fraternity is now suspended last
week police found an unconscious student
who had allegedly been drinking there
the University recently passed stricter
fraternity rules in response to Timothy
piazzas death now you may recall he died
after an alleged hazing ritual at the
Beta Theta Pi House 14 students are
facing misdemeanor charges in connection
with his death
Jericka Duncan is in State College
Pennsylvania outside the Delta Tau Delta
House with the latest on this story
Jericka good morning yeah good morning
those stricter Greek life rules went
into effect six weeks ago now the
University's Office of Student Conduct
is looking into whether students
provided the alcohol and it's still
unclear whether it was a friend a
fraternity member or maybe even a
stranger who flagged down police for
help police say the 18 year old was
found unconscious at 1:30 in the morning
last Friday near a parking lot about six
blocks from the Delta Tau Delta house in
a statement Penn State said the
potential involvement of Delta Tau Delta
is very disturbing news given all the
recent efforts in education that have
gone into emphasizing student safety the
university tightened rules on Greek
organizations after Timothy Piazza died
following an alleged hazing ritual
involving heavy drinking at the Beta
Theta Pi House the reforms include a
temporary ban on social functions
involving alcohol zero-tolerance policy
on hazing and random checks on Greek
organizations but some students are not
surprised to see another fret under fire
for alcohol use that's a common thing in
college campuses whether it be Greek
life if you're talking about drinking
there's a lot of drinking on college
campuses in this country will just get
sneakier and sneakier if you add more
policies on top of it like there's no
it's not going away but Timothy Piazza's
father Jim says he's already hearing
stories of students changing their
behavior
we actually received a text earlier this
morning from a friend and they've
already made a pact that if they're
asked to do anything that they're
uncomfortable with or drink excessive
amounts of alcohol they're gonna leave
they're gonna say no that's what we need
kids doing we need kids saying no to
this type of behavior in a statement
Delta Tau Delta said the health and
safety of members and the guests remain
a top priority we share the University's
commitment to student well-being
recognizing the concerns that led to the
chapters interim suspension by the
university we will continue to work
closely with them during the review of
this situation meanwhile Timothy
Piazza's parents said that they hope
Penn State acts swiftly and meaningfully
Nora agree with that this is another
wake-up call there that other
universities jurika thank you so much